- I give, always, an honor to
being here for the Braves.
My dream was to be a big
leaguer with the Braves,
and I accomplished that.
So, to me, it's like I'm
living the dream right now.
And that's when I got my
tattoo literally saying that.
- OK.
- I had to.
I had to, because everything
was like it was meant to be
at that point.
[Funky upbeat music]
- Ozzie, what's goin’ on?
We are here at Good Kitchen +
Market in Marietta, Georgia.
Why this place of all places?
- Well, I have to take you guys here
because this is one of the
best breakfast/lunch spots
I come to.
- What are the top things on
the menu that we should get?
You mentioned breakfast.
- So, breakfast, I go
always with plain pancakes.
I like plain pancakes.
Some three Italian meatballs.
- [Granderson:] OK.
- That's what I like in the morning.
- [Granderson:] So pancake and meatball?
- Meatballs. I really like the pancakes here.
- OK.
- My favorite spot for pancakes.
- Now is this the go-to
place all the time?
- We come back home from a road trip,
and we have seven games here,
I come here at least three, four times
in that week.
- OK.
Now, obviously Atlanta is
your home away from home.
This is where you play,
this is where you’ve won,
but this isn't where you're from.
- So, I'm originally from Curaçao.
- [Granderson:] All right.
And where is Curaçao located?
- Curaçao is in South America.
It's close located to Venezuela.
- [Granderson:] All right.
- Aruba.
And I mean, just being born
from there and growing up there,
it's one of the best things.
You know, you're on the island,
but there's so much fun stuff to do.
You go off-roading, you
go fishing, swimming,
all those great stuff.
- So, being in Curaçao,
a little bit of the
knowledge I know about it,
and we're sitting here speaking in English,
but this isn't your native language.
- [Chuckling] I know.
- You know, what's your native language?
What's the native language
spoken in Curaçao?
- My native language is Papiamentu.
It's spoken there, Aruba and Bonaire.
- OK.
- So those ABC islands.
- All right.
- That's where it's mainly spoken.
- English has to come into the mix.
- Yes.
- When does English get introduced?
- So, when you go to school,
it's mandatory to learn these languages
- OK.
- So you go to school, you still learn Papiamentu.
- Uh-huh.
- Cuz, you know you're a little kid. You’re starting to talk.
- Right.
- And then you have English, Spanish, Dutch.
- If we're going to eat here,
and I want you to order in Papiamentu,
how do you order what
you're gonna order today?
- So if—
- The pancakes, the meatballs.
- OK, let's do the pancake,
meatballs with bacon and eggs.
- OK.
- So I will say,
“Bon dia.”
That means “good morning.”
- All right.
- Mi ke webu, speki
meatball ku pancake
- All right.
- Just like that.
- Translate it straight through.
So it’d be the pancakes with the eggs.
- Yeah, pancake with the
eggs, with bacon and meatball.
- [Announcer:] Swing and a drive!
[Crowd cheering]
Deep right field! Ozzie Albies
hit it in the Chop House!
- [Granderson:] Now,
did you watch baseball
growing up?
- Yes, always.
- OK. You were a big fan at that time?
- Big fan, yes.
- Favorite team growing up?
- Favorite team,
so me and my grandfather used to watch,
every night, baseball games,
and we watched the Braves and the Dodgers.
- OK.
- Every night.
- Nice.
- That's what his favorite teams were.
So, Braves became my favorite
team because of my grandfather.
- Mmhmm. One of my favorite
teams as well.
One of my favorite players,
also a Curaçao native,
Andruw Jones.
- Andruw Jones.
You guys played together.
- Was he a reason, you know,
that you liked watching the Braves—
- Yes!
- Your grandfather liked
watching the Braves?
- Big reason. A big reason why we
always watched the Braves,
because of Andruw Jones.
You know, we had Hensley Meulens
too, Bam Bam Meulens.
But Andruw Jones, everybody
was—when I grew up,
everybody Andruw Jones,
Andruw Jones, Andruw Jones.
- [Granderson:] Yeah.
- So, I even have a picture with him.
- [Granderson:] Ah. How old were
you when you got that picture?
- Five years old.
I just turned five on that same day.
And my dad surprised me,
the picture with him.
- So, at that time, you're five years old,
and Curaçao is growing
and getting on the map,
the baseball map.
- Mmhmm.
- You got Andruw Jones doing his thing
in the major leagues.
- Yes.
- But you also have the
Little League World Series
being represented by your country,
the Senior League World Series.
Like, teams from your country,
players that you might know or know of,
are playing at the highest
level for the world to see.
Was that influential for you?
- Yes, it was. Yes, it was.
So, like I said, started with Andruw Jones,
but then you heard of
Andrelton Simmons coming up,
Roger Bernadina, all these guys coming,
and Profar, Schoop.
And out of nowhere, something
was, like, in my mind. Like, hey,
I wanna be a major league
baseball player one day, too.
- [Announcer:] Ozzie Albies,
one of the most aggressive
hitters in all of baseball.
The slide, he's safe!
[Crowd cheering]
Oh, my goodness!
- [Announcer:] Think they're
fired up at Truist Park?
You betcha.
- So take me through last year:
The Braves are gettin' hot.
We enter the playoffs.
How was that just from
a mental standpoint?
For you personally, for the team?
You know, how did that all unfold?
- The year before, we lost in the NLCS.
- Yeah.
And we were like, "OK,
this year is our year.
We have to go for it, and
we have to win whole thing.
We're not gonna just be
in it. We have to win.”
So going into it mentally,
you know, you work the whole
season for these moments.
- Yeah.
- So when we got there,
it's all about “Let's go take care of
what we need to take care of.”
- Right.
“Don't think about the
roads we're gonna face,
all the people, the teams.
Let's go just focus on us.”
We did that. And like everybody saw,
that's what got us to the World Series.
Now we're here together as one team.
And that's what we did.
- [Granderson:] So you won together.
- Oh, yes. Won together. We couldn't
do it by ourselves, the only chance.
- How was the celebration?
- Ooh. [Chuckling]
- In Atlanta, you win the World Series.
This is the hope and dream of kids
that wanna play baseball.
- Yes, yes.
- And now you've just accomplished it.
- Just get to the World
Series, getting there,
was the biggest thing for me.
- Yeah.
- Cuz you always see this on TV.
You've never been there physically.
Like, oh yeah, the World Series.
But being there, as soon
as I step in Houston,
I remember, first game, I look around.
I was like, “This is it.”
- Were you nervous?
- No.
- No? OK.
- I was excited.
Excitement like,
“OK, here is what I worked
my whole life for, the ring.”
- Yeah.
- And went in,
I remember getting into the
first when I got the stolen base.
I’m like, “This is really happening.”
- Mmhmm.
- I couldn't believe it.
So, I would say one of the most
amazing moments in my life, the World Series.
- [Granderson:] That's awesome.
How was it when you went back home?
- When I went back home,
they did a whole parade just for me.
- Soon as you land?
- As soon as I land, they put
me on one of those big cars—
- Yeah.
- And just drive me through
the whole Curaçao.
- Wow. Everybody came out to see you?
- Every—oh, my God, it was an amazing moment.
- That’s awesome.
It was a whole parade, just me on there.
[Rhythmic music]
- There were also four
other Curaçao players
that played for the Braves before you.
- Yes.
- Randall Simon, Andrelton
Simmons, Andruw Jones,
Jair Jurrjens. You're the fifth.
You get a sixth Curaçao player,
- Exactly. [Laughing]
- Kenley Jansen.
- Yes.
- [Granderson:] Joins you and the Braves.
- I remember him calling me and saying,
"Hey, I signed with the Braves.”
I said, “Perfect.”
- Nice.
- “Let's go,
and let's go to win the World
Series this year together.”
That's what, that's our goal right now.
And he got to Atlanta.
I show him some cool restaurants.
We go together, we eat, we enjoy.
Travel with the team,
we sit together, talk.
You know, always have
fun with a group of guys
playing Uno and all
this stuff on the plane.
But I really liked the way—
first time it ever happened to me too,
having a Curaçao guy on the same team.
So, it was actually a great moment
for him to be on the team.
He came, he actually came to the
restaurant here with me, too.
- OK. You brought him here?
- We ate here together, too.
- Do you remember what
you had to eat that day?
- Pancakes and everything.
He loves pancakes also.
- Good, good.
- And, you know, he's a big boy.
he likes to eat this whole thing.
- [Granderson:] Winning one is great.
- Mmhmm.
- But winning two would be even better.
Kenley has a ring with the Dodgers.
You have a ring with the Braves.
You two getting two rings together?
- That would be amazing.
It's gonna be the
biggest parade in Curaçao
if that happened.
It would be amazing.
We gotta go get it together now.
- Right.
- We're on the same team.
Let's make history. Let's go!
- Continue to do
it and live that dream, that tattoo.
- Always.
- Let me see that tattoo one more time.
- Always, always.
- Live the dream.
- Always.
I will always do that.
- Keep living the dream.
- I will.
- It's been an absolute pleasure.
- Thank you so much.
- And thanks for the recommendation.
- Mmhmm.
- When I'm in Marietta, I'm
coming to Good Kitchen + Market,
and I'm gonna get the pancakes next time.
- Yes, please.
- All right.
- You'll enjoy it.